[Musique]
reverra-t-on encore des scènes comme
celle là si cet homme sorti des
décombres hier vivra le sort de dizaines
de personnes toujours disparues inquiète
les recherches pour trouver des
survivants dans les ruines de beyrouth
se poursuivre
le colonel vincent tessier du
détachement de la sécurité civile
envoyés par la france au liban se veut
confiant devant emmanuel macron il
estime que les chances de retrouver les
disparus sont toujours importantes
donc on recherche sept ou huit
personnels disparus qui seraient coincés
dans une salle de commande enterré par
l'explosion dans cette direction à
environ 400 mètres
avec les renseignements que nous allons
confirmer la présence de personnes dans
une salle fermée qui a été enseveli on
pense qu'être bon espoir de retrouver
des victimes des personnes qui votent
parallèlement le nettoyage de la ville
commence si l'armée envoie des bulldozer
pour déblayer les routes c'est les
services municipaux de la capitale
s'organisent pour le nettoiement des
actions bien souvent réalisées avec
l'aide des habitants représentant le
syndicat des municipalités de la
banlieue sud ainsi que ces municipalités
12 oeuvres ont actuellement pour retirer
les décombres et nettoyer les rues nous
avons participé à la lutte contre les
incendies et au transport des blessés
vers les hôpitaux de la banlieue sud et
nous avons lancé une initiative pour
héberger les personnes des quartiers
touchés afin que nous puissions les
recevoir dans nos maisons
aujourd'hui en optimisant les capacités
disponibles
toute l'équipe des pompiers de la
banlieue sud en coordination avec la
brigade des pompiers de la ville de
beyrouth et toutes les personnes
concernées sur le terrain travaillent à
nettoyer la ville autant que possible
l'objectif est vital relogés au maximum
les 300 mille personnes qui selon le
gouverneur de la ville sont aujourd'hui
sans abri
et il ya urgence selon le franco
libanais mego terzian président de
médecins sans frontières
notre priorité dans les jours à venir
sera le suivi de ces populations
déplacées
l'autre priorité sont les malades
chroniques ceux atteints de cancer du
vih ou des maladies respiratoires comme
l'asthme avec le risque de rupture de
l'approvisionnement en médicaments
nous avons par ailleurs aussi appris que
des entrepôts de médicaments et de
vaccins situé dans le port de beyrouth
avait été endommagée pour l'air marwan
abou de le gouverneur de beyrouth a
estimé le coût des dommages à plus de 3
milliards de dollars